vor wenigen Wochen in Berlin die
erdgasbranche trifft sich und sie hat
ein Problem erdgas ist teuer und
klimaschädlich doch die Gaswirtschaft
präsentiert eine Lösung sogenannter
grüner Wasserstoff zum Heizen definitiv
die Gasheizung hat an den Zukunft
insbesondere dann in der Nähe und der
Grünen Wasserstoff einsetzen für uns ist
es als städtischer Betreiber ganz
wichtig bis 2030 die heutigen Gasnetze
fit zu machen für den Energieträger
Wasserstoff Erdgasheizung sukzessive zur
Wasserstoff Heizung werden das heißt wir
müssen die Netze nutzen die wir jetzt
haben müssen Wasserstoff reinbringen und
irgendwann alle Verbraucher machen dann
Wasserstoff doch bisher wird grüner
Wasserstoff kaum produziert weil er so
teuer ist in Zukunft soll in großen
Anlagen Wasser aufgespalten werden in
Sauerstoff und das brennbare Gas
Wasserstoff
nur wenn der Strom dafür aus Windparks
oder Solaranlagen stammt spricht man von
grünem Wasserstoff
weil Deutschland nicht genügend Ökostrom
hat muss Bundeskanzler Scholz ins ferne
Kanada reisen Kanada wird für die
Entwicklung des grünen Wasserstoffs eine
ganz ganz zentrale Rolle spielen ab 2025
soll Kanada grünen Wasserstoff nach
Deutschland liefern für die Industrie
nicht zum Heizen dafür ist der
Wasserstoff viel zu teuer
in Deutschland testet die Gaswirtschaft
wie Leitungen und Netz umgerüstet werden
müssen damit statt Erdgas Wasserstoff
fließen kann
[Musik]
hier befinden uns auf einen Testfeld für
Wasserstoff und das ist eine
Versuchsstation wo wir 100% Wasserstoff
Testen zu dem Testfeld in Bitterfeld
gehört auch ein eigener Showroom dort
hängt an der Wand was die Gaswirtschaft
den Deutschen als Heizung der Zukunft
verkaufen möchte
das sind zwei Geräte die sind für 100%
Wasserstoff konzipiert für die
Wärmeerzeugung im ein und
zweifamilienhausbereich so wünscht sich
die Gaswirtschaft das die Verbraucher
tauschen ihre Gasheizungen aus und durch
das Erdgasnetz strömt grüner Wasserstoff
das heißt die Moleküle das Gas soll
weiter in die Häuser strömen das ist
wichtig das würde uns freuen jetzt fehlt
nur noch der grüne Wasserstoff zum
Heizen
das wird dieser grüne Wasserstoff Kosten
das kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen was er
kostenlos es gibt noch keinen Markt
dafür wie dieser Markt aussehen könnte
hat der nationale wasserstoffrat der
Bundesregierung untersucht frontal
liegen die Ergebnisse vor heizen mit
grünem Wasserstoff das wird teuer
Experten wundert das nicht
wir wollen ja das Haushalten denn Ihre
Heizung auch bezahlen können und das ist
mit grünem Wasserstoff aus heutiger
Sicht keineswegs sichergestellt
das heißt es ist völlig unklar zu
welchem Preis der jemals hier in
Deutschland zur Verfügung stehen wird ja
das ist aus unserer Sicht völlig unklar
Lemgo in Ostwestfalen die Stadt will
nicht warten auf grünen Wasserstoff
grüner Wasserstoff für die Wärme in
gaskesseln ist nicht der Weg das kann es
nicht sein weil wir die nicht
kostengünstig an diesen Wasserstoff
kommen die Stadt sitzt stattdessen auf
Fernwärme schon heute ist jeder zweite
Haushalt an das Fernwärmenetz
angeschlossen
ein Teil der Wärme kommt von der neuen
Solarthermieanlage einer der größten in
Deutschland und die Wärme stammt auch
von dem Klärwerk der Stadt da haben wir
zum einen den Standort hier in der Nähe
wo wir dieses Abwasser nutzen hier vom
Klärwerk das Abwasser ist warm auch im
Winter diese Wärme wird genutzt für die
Wärmepumpe auch die eine der größten in
Deutschland auf die ist Georg Lehne
besonders stolz die Wärmepumpe macht aus
der Abwärme vom Abwasser mit einer
Kilowattstunde Strom dreimal so viel
Wärme für das Fernwärmenetz der Stadt
das ist sehr effizient aufgrund der
Nutzung erneuerbare Wärme können wir ein
sehr günstigen ferienpreis anbieten der
ist jetzt schon günstiger als das Erdgas
und perspektivisch wird er natürlich
auch günstiger sein als der Preis für
Wasserstoff die Wärmepumpe ist besonders
günstig weil sie mit wenig Ökostrom viel
Wärme erzeugt würde mit Ökostrom erst
grüner Wasserstoff produziert und damit
dann die Wärme bräuchte es vier bis fünf
Mal so viel Ökostrom für die gleiche
Wärmemenge deshalb haben die Stadtwerke
Lemgo eine klare Entscheidung getroffen
wie sie ihren Windpark nutzen
wir haben hier sechs Windkraftanlagen im
Hintergrund die die von den Strom für
unsere Wärmepumpen in lemgut mit denen
ihr die Fernwärme machen wenn man das
mit Wasserstoff dezentral machen wollte
und den Kessel verheizen wollte da
brauche ich mir ungefähr vier bis fünf
Mal so viel Windanlagen wie wir sie da
jetzt sehen im Hintergrund bereits 2035
will die Stadt Lemgo klimaneutral heizen
ohne grünen Wasserstoff für Gasheizungen
Lemgo ist die Ausnahme die meisten
Stadtwerke in Deutschland halten an
ihrem Erdgasnetz fest damit verdienen
sie gutes Geld zuletzt rund 10
Milliarden Euro Umsatz
zurück nach Berlin auf dem
Branchentreffen der Gaswirtschaft
erklärt der Gastgeber wieder Wechsel zum
grünen Wasserstoff gelingen soll erstmal
nur ein bisschen die Gasheizung hat als
H2 ready Gasheizung eine Zukunft wir
haben getestet das bestehende Geräte mit
ungefähr 20% Wasserstoff bei Mischung
weiter betrieben werden können und das
reicht erstmal für viele viele Jahre hat
es nicht mehr sinnvoll das ganze mit
Wärmepumpen zu betreiben weil die
Effizienz doch viel höher ist nein das
macht grundsätzlich keinen Sinn man muss
sich immer das Objekt anschauen und das
es geht in der Tat ist es so dass eine
Elektrowärmepumpe die Lösung sein kann
im Neubau bei hoch energieeffizienten
Häusern aber im Bestand nicht generell
Wärmepumpen funktionieren nur im Neubau
also nur in wenigen Fällen das sei nicht
richtig sagt Malik im Jahre vom
Frauenhofer Institut er hat mehr als 100
Wärmepumpen im Bestand also im Altbau
untersucht
ja es geht auf jeden Fall unsere Studien
die wir seit 20 Jahren machen haben
gezeigt dass die Wärmepumpen nicht nur
im Neubau sondern durchaus auch im
Altbau effizient und gut arbeiten können
die Häuser sind warm die Wärmepumpen
laufen problemlos also es geht auf jeden
Fall auch im Altbau dennoch redet die
Gasbranche die Wärmepumpe klein das
verfängt bei der zuständigen
bauministerin
also insofern sind wir überzeugt dass
die Wärmepumpe gerade im Neubau
natürlich ein ganz ganz große Rolle
spielen wird aber dass sie auch nicht
dass Allheilmittel ist Wärmepumpe für
den Neubau die Ministerin übernimmt die
zweifelhafte Behauptung der gaslobby und
sie ist gegen einen schnellen Ausstieg
aus Gasheizungen
wir unterstützen vielmehr ein sehr
technologieoffenen Ansatz mit vielen
anderen Optionen der Wärme
Bereitstellung sie haben das erwähnt mit
dem Wasserstoff das hört die
Gaswirtschaft gerne solange Politik und
Verbraucher auf den grünen Wasserstoff
warten läuft das profitable Geschäft mit
dem teuren und klimaschädlichen Erdgas
weiter